we're here with women's Grand Master
Sabina for sure Sabina you've had a lot
of strong starts in the past year at the
u.s. women's Chess Championship what's
it going to take for that kind of
success to last over a full fortnight I
don't know in my first two years at
first year I played pretty well in the
second it was really bad and last year
it was a surprise for me too well you
probably had the strongest chess
pedigree of any player here both of your
parents are titled players and your
sister is very strong just coming from a
chess-playing family give you a benefit
or does it give you maybe extra
expectations having my family play chess
they can always talk to me and help me
if I have any questions about a specific
opening or some opponents but it also
there's a little bit of pressure because
I always want to show them that I'm
going to no one to be better than there
so would your goal be with one of your
goals be to one day pass through parents
and then rating and ability yeah but not
only that because that's a rating I
don't think is the the most important
thing is what's most important in my
opinion is to actually play better and
show a better understanding of chess
rather than just have a high rating so
for all those teenagers out there that
doubt their parents with them they just
need to look to you and say in a couple
years it'll all be worth it them they
will see later on that all this words
they're putting into chess it's or not
necessary chess but whatever their
parents are trying to push them a little
bit to do it will be definitely helpful
so you said you're graduating soon from
UMBC are you gonna stay in the space
what's your degree in and what are your
plans I have been majoring in modern
language and linguistics with
concentration and French
and I had two minors in psychology and
Russian and I planned to stay at the
Embassy for the master's in
intercultural communication well I don't
know how you do it but Romanians are
always like the best polyglots in the
world and you're adding to a long line
of it it's a latin language so it's
really easier to learn more languages
like French Spanish Italian Hertz
so in English or suggests you have to
learn English when you're just wearing
my opinion so well you know your fans
wish you well in trying to win your
first u.s. women's change that would be
great thank you good luck to you